so you got a thousand dollars a week the
show takes and i saved a lot of it
because i'm a big saver
i do that too and then how long before
you call sylvester your friend from the
movie he calls me
uh he drove out here with all of his
possessions
his first wife sasha and their dog right
this bull mastiff right
his car breaks down sunset boulevard
henry come and get me
i said okay
i drove in and the first audi ever made
which i then used as a planter about a
week later because it never worked
picked him up you know we're sponsored
by audi
i'm so sorry but these are different
audis
doesn't matter we just lost them oh it's
okay but this is a different audi okay
this was the first audi yeah then they
went back and they thought maybe we
should make a car that works right and
now they're beautiful well there's other
brands that will probably hop on board
go ahead okay
all right
so i pick him up
all of his stuff
and his dog is in the back seat
drooling
or me like
inches thick you need like
a bathing suit to go back in that back
seat with that dog
i take him to his apartment which is
also on one of those side streets off of
sunset boulevard el camino or whatever
it's called
and
he says i got a script
and i take this script to abc
i said here is a script
do you like it they said yes they give
us money and then they said
and i said to sly
i got good news here's your money i got
bad news what did they pay for the
script i don't remember
i do not remember
and they said we want to replace
the writer
i said the bad news is sly they want to
replace you
he said don't let them do that to me
i said okay
but he had no money he had no money
ah but
this this is who he really is
uh so um
i go back to abc and i said
i need the script back they said we
don't do that i said i know i know but
here's all your money i just need that
script back we don't do that i know you
don't do that but here it is there's
always a first time
i really need that script back and thank
god
i had a little bit of a cachet
being the fonz
they gave me the script back how long
have you been doing the show at this
point now i've been doing it for at
least two or three years oh so it's
number one that's that you're on the
number one show
they give me the script back i give it
to sly
about a year and a half later
rocky comes out
they had in their hands rocky
but you gave it back to him i did so if
you didn't fight if you didn't fight
they probably would have put another
writer on it like they were going to do
right and it wouldn't be the movie no it
wouldn't so
no because it's his vision
i mean so does he realize what you did
for him by even getting it back he has
to he does are you guys still friends
you know what we're acquaintances i have
not seen him
in 30 years
but there is a wonderful
warmth
between us
that i know exists because i hear from
people who do see him
right because that's
so not only was that
life changing for
sylvester stallone right but i think
it's iconic in our world that
that character that movie the fact that
it's just part of it doesn't matter what
generation you're from i think everybody
knows what rocky is oh my god and they
wouldn't if you weren't a good friend
you know what you when
i you know who your friend is you know
the talent in there you hear
the plea you hear him honestly
he literally cannot
live with himself if
his baby
that he's been riding in that apartment
in new york having painted his windows
black
was given
to somebody else to just make
pablum out of
[Music]